hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in albert camus myth of sisyphus there
is
a section called absurd freedom and in
that
portion of the text which is also going
to include the introduction of his
ethics of
quantity he is drawing out
some of the implications for us
of the the doctrine of the absurd or the
realization
of the absurd and
if we take this seriously in his view we
are going to revise our
conceptions of freedom we're going to
realize that some of them
aren't really that helpful that they're
illusions when it comes down to it
and we replace them with something else
and he calls this a
liberation and you know that's a good
term to use liberation
means being granted freedom so
by getting straight about what sort of
freedom we really
have and liberating ourselves or freeing
ourselves of
other notions of freedom we in fact
become more free or at least we become
free in the sense that that according to
him human beings can be free
so this this section begins by
reiterating some points that he's made
earlier
in the text about the human condition he
says
i hold certain facts from which i cannot
separate this is all the earlier
development he says what i know what is
certain what i cannot deny what i cannot
reject
this is what counts he's carried out
this process of analysis
he's also carried out some critique of
the existentialists for engaging in
in a sort of philosophical suicide and
now he's got some things that he can
rely on what are they
he says i can negate everything of that
part of me that lives on vague
nostalgias
except this desire for unity this
longing
to solve this need for clarity and
cohesion
so the human being is caught within
it's not even a dilemma because you you
can't choose it once and for all
it's a perpetual condition that
has its its uh roots down into our
affective
being we have a desire for something
that cannot really exist he says
that i can refute everything in this
world that offends or enraptures me
except this chaos this sovereign chance
this divine equivalence which springs
from anarchy i don't know whether this
world has a meaning that transcends it
i do know that i don't know that meaning
and that it is impossible for me
just now to know it and so this is you
know if you
think about what he's saying here it
seems very dogmatic in some respects but
it's also very careful
and measured there could be some sort of
meaning to life i don't know what it is
i don't know how to find it
whatever it's going to be if it's going
to appeal to me it's going to have to be
on my
terms and i'm just not finding anything
like that
so we come to the triad of the absurd
which is that it's not just the world
that's absurd
right it is the desire on my part for
things to actually make sense
the fact that the world if it does make
sense it doesn't make sense in the way
that i wanted to and then there's this
divorce
between us camus said earlier that the
absurd
encompasses all three of these
so you don't have just an absurd world
by itself
the world is absurd because of the
demands that we
make upon it and even on ourselves as
things
in the world so awareness
of this conflict is going to be
what's what's really important and he's
got this interesting passage where he
says if i were a tree among trees a cat
among animals
this life would have a meaning and then
he takes that back immediately and says
or rather this problem would not arise i
would belong to this world
i would be this world to which i am now
opposed by my whole
consciousness and my whole insistence on
familiarity
this ridiculous reason is what sets me
in
opposition right so he goes on and he
says
you know this is the conflict this is
the basis of the conflict the break
between the world
and my mind it lies in our
awareness of it and that seem may seem
like a very
you know simple thing to get rid of why
not just
uh you know take some drugs
and numb yourself to it or find an
ideology that will tell you the meaning
of the world
you can do that a human being is free to
do whatever they want
that is part of what you know camus
calls a certain kind of suicide though
not remaining with the absurd and so he
advocates something that he calls a
method
one of persisting he says it is a matter
of persisting at a certain point on his
path
the absurd man is tempted at not just a
certain point over and over again
we live in cultures that are tempting us
right
but so there's this method of persisting
and he says that
now this is quite interesting because
he's making us a sort of promise
here that might not pan out for
everybody he tells us
a little bit earlier than that he says
let's make a final effort in this regard
draw
all of our conclusions the body
affection creation action
human nobility will then resume their
places in this
mad world that's a list that's worth
dwelling on for a moment the body right
the body that we
are or inhabit however we're going to
think about it that's a key theme
for uh phenomenological and existential
philosophy in the 20th century this this
what is this thing that i am right and
you could also say
that in part for the french this is part
of their heritage of
cartesianism right how do you explain
the junction between the body
and whatever it is that transcends the
body that i am conscious of being
right uh affection all the affective
states
that we encounter creation now what does
he mean there he's not talking about
divine creation
he's talking about creative work
of artists of novelists like himself
playwrights of anybody who is engaging
in doing something that brings something
new into the world even if it's not
completely radically new
action the whole domain of ethics right
then he says human nobility
oftentimes existentialism is viewed as
this you know very cynical philosophy
it unveils the fact that we're all a
bunch of bastards deep down inside and
you might even like look at you know
camus
companion piece to this the stranger
and the character marceau and be like
see look at that but camus says no no
human nobility is
possible even in this this world that
we find to be you know in our relation
to it absurd
so how do we get that back well
through this method of persisting and he
talks about the temptations
that we could encounter he says history
is not lacking in religions prophets
evens without even without gods were
asked to leap it could be you know
joining the communist party
it could be believing in capitalism and
the invisible hand
and you know third way uh whatever it's
going to be
however it's going to be framed you know
liberalism it could be anything that you
like it could be the
hope and the singularity and the ais
figuring everything out for us
those are all leaps from kamu's
perspective
and so he goes on and he says if we
resist this temptation
we take a certain stance we don't want
to do anything but what we fully
understand
and that is you know viewed by other
people as the sin of pride
he tells us that this is a kind of
innocence
uh what we feel is irreparable innocence
that's what allows us
everything and so he says what he
demands of himself is to live solely
with what he knows
to accommodate himself to what is to
bring in nothing that is not certain
he is told that nothing is certain that
is but this at least is a certainty
and he says can he find is it possible
for him to live
can he find a way to live
as he says without appeal and
camus calls this a kind of metaphysical
revolt a way of saying
no to how things are set up and he tells
us
the theme of permanent revolution is
carried into individual
existence what is this theme of
permanent revolution again
a bit of background in 20th century
we might we could say broader
continental thought
this idea that there would be like a
continual redoing
of things and camus doesn't think that
that works
socially politically you know he's he's
uh
not pessimistic but he's realistic about
movements
but he thinks it could be done on an
individual level
and that would be a way of of preserving
freedom
so he tells us instead of renunciation
what we should be aiming at that we
already have to some degree is
consciousness
and revolt we should be continually
not hiding things from ourselves not
allowing ourselves to slip into
fantasies
or you know you might say a sort of
consumerism
and we could say consumerism very
broadly so it's not just the economic
marketplace but the
marketplace of attention and ideas as
well
we should avoid any sort of utopianism
we should also avoid any sort of
do-nothing cynicism
or misanthropy instead all of those
would be forms of renunciation
consciousness remaining conscious of the
absurdity that we're
within and revolt against it
by contrast you know suicide whether it
be physical suicide or
philosophical suicide he says suicide is
acceptance at its extreme everything is
over and the human being returns to
their essential
history their future their unique and
dreadful future
he sees it and rushes towards it suicide
settles the absurd it engulfs the absurd
in
death in order to keep alive the absurd
cannot be
settled so you have to remain within the
painful condition
within the condition of not being able
to say once and for all the way things
are and so you might say well what does
all this have to do with freedom well
this is setting up the stage
to liberate oneself of these temptations
is in a certain sense freedom and he
goes on
before he he jumps into actually talking
about freedom he says a few other things
he says revolt gives life its value
spread over the whole length of a life
it restores its majesty to that life
to a person devoid of blinders there is
no finer sight than that of the
intelligence at grips
with a reality that transcends it the
reality that we're in
that of the the world and that of the
absurd
so he says to impoverish that reality
whose inhumanity constitutes
human majesty is tantamount to
impoverishing
one oneself so he says consciousness and
revolt these rejections are the contrary
of renunciation
everything that is indomitable and
passionate a human heart quickens them
on the contrary with its own life it's
not it's essential to die unreconciled
and not of one's own free will and you
can say well
that sounds awfully unfree right dying
uh without your
your choice of dying isn't that the
opposite of freedom and
in a way it is freedom is taken away you
can no longer do anything
but you have the freedom to say no
so let's talk now where he
goes explicitly into discussing freedom
he calls this the
second paradox and the second paradox is
in order to remain
faithful to my method i have nothing to
do with the problem of metaphysical
liberty what is he talking about there
so this is the traditional problem that
we introduce people
to in intro to philosophy classes and
textbooks
and that so many psychologists salivate
over and
love to get into even though they're
usually not qualified to talk much about
it
and haven't done much of the literature
review of the problem of
are we as as the kind of beings that we
are do we actually have real freedom or
are we stuck in a universe of causes
chained to each other
so that one causes the the effect uh
you know from another cause all the way
down to a determinism that covers
everything is there
a space for liberty and what would it
look like is it a liberty of
indifference
camus says i don't care about any of
that stuff i mean i do care about it
it's interesting
uh if i have to talk about it i'll talk
about it it's not
relevant to what i'm doing here
is what he's saying and this is a very
radical step is it not
right he's setting aside this problem
why he says knowing whether or not man
is free doesn't interest me i can only
experience
my own freedom as to it i have no
general notions
i can have no general notions but merely
a few clear
insights the problem of freedom as such
has no meaning it's too abstract
it's it's turned into sort of a textbook
case
and people make all sorts of arguments
about it but their arguments aren't you
know particularly
on point when it comes to the the
concrete lived reality that we're in
you know people spend all sorts of ink
or pixels now
to demonstrate that there is no freedom
it's just an illusion
and they're they're off target as far as
camus is concerned
he also points out another thing he says
that this problem of freedom is linked
in a different way with the problem of
god
knowing whether or not man is free
involves knowing whether or not
he can have a master the absurdity
peculiar to this problem notice that
he's saying this
problem itself is absurd go back earlier
in the
the book and you notice him talking
about some of the stances people get
into philosophically absurd
so he says the absurdity comes from the
fact that the very notion that makes the
problem of freedom possible takes away
its meaning
in the presence of god there's less a
problem of freedom than a problem of
evil you know the alternative either
we're not free and god the all-powerful
is responsible for evil
or we're free and responsible but god is
not all-powerful and so he's going to
set that aside
and he says i cannot get lost in the
glorification or mere
definition of a notion which eludes me
and loses its meaning
as soon as it goes beyond the frame of
reference of my individual experience
i don't understand what kind of freedom
would be given to me by
a higher being i've lost a sense of
hierarchy and he goes on and says
something really interesting
he tells us that the only
freedom the only conception of freedom i
can have is that of the prisoner or the
individual in the midst of the state
the only one i know is freedom of
thought and
action right so that's my experience of
freedom all this metaphysical stuff
that's very nice
we'll put that aside and then he says
there's a liberation taking place here
if the absurd cancels all my chances of
eternal freedom it restores and
magnifies
on the other hand my freedom of action
and then there's one other thing he says
in that that immediately following
that really expands this that privation
of hope and future
means an increase in man's availability
this the the capacity to
be there to lend oneself to things to
to to act on a human level
so he's he's set aside this this problem
of metaphysical liberty
what do we get then what is this
experience of freedom here he's going to
make a contrast between
before and after the awareness of the
absurd and then two different
possibilities
with awareness of the absurd so he tells
us before encountering the absurd the
everyday person lives with aims
a concern with the future or for
justification
they weigh their chances they count on
someday retirement the labor of their
children
they still think that something in their
life can be directed
so one of the basic ideas
or not even ideas assumptions governing
human action is that
we can make choices that are meaningful
we can predict to some degree
even if we can't control entirely so he
says he still thinks something in his
life can be directed which
means that he acts as if he were free
even if all the facts make a point of
contradicting that liberty and all the
facts don't have to be
metaphysical stuff it could be stuff
like i'm gonna you know
think about my retirement and one of the
facts could be
hyperinflation destroys the savings that
i have
and now i just don't have that now i now
have to rethink what i'm doing i
some freedom has been taken away from me
something i i planned for
so he says uh after the absurd
everything is upset
that idea that i am my way of acting as
if everything has a meaning
all that has been given the lie in
vertiginous
fashion by the absurdity of a possible
death now why
why focus on death there he doesn't
actually need to he could bring in
other things as well other forms of
things going awry
but death is you know ultimate right it
could be that i make all these great
plans
and i walk out and bam i get hit by the
bus
or you know safe as in cartoons falls on
my head which actually does happen in
in real life people get killed by pianos
coming down
i mean it's kind of ridiculous and
absurd isn't it that sometimes
life imitates not just art but the you
know mass production
art of silly entertainment cartoons well
that's that's the way things sometimes
work so
there's an awareness that's that's being
developed here and he tells us
this awareness is that
the higher liberty that freedom to be
which alone can serve
as a basis for truth it doesn't exist
i don't need that though it says death
is there is the only reality
after death the chips are down i'm not
even free to perpetuate myself but a
slave
and a slave without hope of eternal
revolution
and so what kind of freedom can exist
without assurance of eternity and he
says well the freedom of the absurd
person so there's a compensation here
realization uh you know that that's
taking place
before that though he talks about
another realization he says the absurd
man
realizes that hitherto he was bound to
that postulate
of freedom on the illusion of which he
was living in a certain sense that
hampered him
to the extent which he imagined the
purpose of this life he adapted himself
to the demands of a purpose to be
achieved became slave of liberty
and this involves the social world this
involves
more than just me and my relation to the
world
it involves the entire realm of
interconnected meanings
that are what we call culture society
right
even the branches of it that we you know
distinguishes entertainment politics law
religion uh day-to-day work
getting on the subway you know transit
philosophy
we were engaged in a adaptation to the
social world of others
and that's in many respects unfree he
lingers on this and he says
i think i can choose to be this or that
rather than something else i think so
unconsciously
at the same time i strengthen my
postulate with the beliefs of those
around me
with the presumptions of my human
environment
but you know as in so far as i'm
adapting my
life to them the absurd person realizes
they weren't truly free
what happens when you become conscious
of the absurdity and remain within it
you're like well a lot of this is
bs i actually don't have to buy into
this sort of stuff i don't have to
do what's expected of me i can do what's
expected of me but do it my own way
on my own terms that is so liberating to
realize
right so there's this new possibility of
what he calls
an inner freedom before that though
he says
here we go the absurd man realizes he
was not truly free
in accepting the meaning of having a
i create for myself barriers between
which i can find my life i do so
and now i can reject that i can i can
you know
adopt an inner freedom and he says the
absurd enlightens me on this point there
is no future i can't rely on anything
this is the reason for is he says my
inner freedom and he brings up
he calls them two comparisons here he's
not trying to outline
all of the possibilities of inner
freedom but he's using this to contrast
against
the mystics he's in just a bit going to
talk about the existentialists as well
so what does he think that mystics do
mystics
find freedom in giving themselves losing
themselves in their god
accepting the rules they become secretly
free but he calls this
a spontaneously accepted slavery in
which they discover a deeper
independence
and he says what does that actually mean
it may it may be said they feel free
um with respect with regard to
themselves but not so much free is
liberated
and he says the absurd person does
something different
they're released from everything outside
that passionate attention
crystallizing in him he enjoys the
freedom with regard to common rules
here he says the existentialists start
out right
they they get it to some degree and then
what camus is calling existentialists uh
you know of course are not the entire
range of the existentialist movement
which often includes him but people like
kierkegaard shestop
jaspers he says that they make a leap
into
the absurd essentially as god and in
doing so they're
they're committing philosophical suicide
so we don't want to follow them there
but their original starting point is
dead on
right everything is up to us he says
uh in in the same way the slaves of
antiquity did not belong to themselves
they knew that freedom which consists
in not feeling responsible so losing
oneself in that bottomless certainty
feeling
remote from one's life to increase it
and take a broad view of it this
involves the principle of a liberation
and it takes play the place of illusions
right so he calls this reasonable
freedom
the divine availability of the condemned
man before whom
the prison doors open in a certain early
dawn
uh it is clear that death and the absurd
are here the principles of the only
reasonable freedom that which a human
heart
can experience and live and
this is coming back to the the original
starting point we are caught within a
human condition according to
kamu it is one in which we can
experience
freedom and not just experience it
passively
but also you might say make use of it
actively and it doesn't have to be
connected to some sort of
grounding or far off heaven or anything
like that of pure freedom of
metaphysical freedom
we can actually do without that and
still be free and thereby responsible
beings
you